hey guys I'm Greg Benson of mediocre
films Brussels sprouts talks are in
cinnamon swirl bread makes the greatest
french toast ever I'm about to start
talking to you guys about a food-related
movie but before I do that you should
check out what's in the fridge a show
that shows you what is in youtubers
fridges let's look in mine
Oh leftover meatballs how applicable
check out what's in the fridge and
subscribe and let them know the crisps
stuckman sent you let me make a quick
suggestion if you guys are in any way a
hungry before this movie starts eat
because you're going to be starving by
the time it ends better late than never
right I actually did see Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatballs 2 last weekend but I
have been really sick this week and
haven't hardly even been able to talk so
I haven't really been able to tell you
guys my thoughts on the film but now I
can so basically in this film the full
erm NIF flurry or whatever it's called
has created an entire island filled with
food animals and some of them are
carnivorous and this scientist who runs
this big corporation sends various other
people to the island to try to find out
what's going on hopefully to save this
island and stop all of this chaos that's
creating because it could possibly
spread to other islands now I kind of
enjoyed the first Cloudy with a Chance
of Meatballs I thought it was a pretty
inventive and clever comedy I liked the
humor behind it I liked the animation
and while the second film still has
really good animation and some pretty
funny moments I found it to be a pretty
scatterbrained sequel where it wasn't
even remotely as inventive as the first
one which is interesting because the
main character is an inventor so you
think this film would be more inventive
I took my fiancee to the movie and she
remarked that it was a good film for the
family kids will enjoy it and the adults
can probably enjoy it too and it has
some good morals behind it and I can
agree with that if you're an adult
you're not going to want to die as this
film plays and a kid will probably
really enjoy it but it doesn't really
have the needed emotional substance for
me to be able to care that much about
these characters it's also extremely
predictable I mean like it's like
everything from sea
I knew exactly I was going to play out
so I'm going to give you a spoiler
warning because I can't really get into
my thoughts that much about why certain
things were very predictable for me
unless I spoil certain elements for you
so you have been warned the first scene
in the movie is our main character and
he's watching this scientist and he
loves a scientist so much he respects
his older guy he wants to be him he
wants to grow up and just be just like
him I knew from scene one that guy's
going to be the villain and it's a
complete ripoff of up the exact same
thing happened in up exact same thing
when the ape character is called a
monkey over and over again by the
scientist I was like she's gonna
eventually start to hate that so much
because she hates being called a monkey
she's going to become a good guy in the
end she's going to help them and turn on
him because he keeps calling her monkey
and of course it happened and with the
carnivorous food animals that need to be
killed in the children's film I was like
never never going to happen they're
going to be lovely animals they're going
to want to take care of their families
and of course that's exactly what
happened and that's really the thing
that bugged me the most about this movie
was it was so predictable and cliched I
didn't find one thing about it that was
original or different it was just like a
copy of other animated films which was
kind of depressing to me because I
really liked the first one so for that
reason I can't really recommend seeing
this it does however have really good
animation and some funny moments in
there some likeable characters but it is
a very predictable movie and I think
there are better family films out there
I'm going to give Cloudy with a Chance
of Meatballs 2 a c+ thanks as always
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes